retreat his night no he brings it  forward we do see a trade of knights  oh magnus is not happy he's reacting  here what is he reacting about why is he  angry  i don't really understand why he's angry  surely i mean that was white's  most obvious move that was white's only  move um and there's nothing too terrible  with black's position  um right now the world champion just  doubting himself i think he's just  um i think he thinks he's going to  suffer in an endgame  and a long long end game and it's going  to be  suffering because of those pawns on the  left side and he's just  focused in focusing on that um  i think there's only maybe one move for  magnus carson not to suffer right now  and he has to find it he has to use the  black bishop and capture white's pawn  there  on that left side so that's the only  move for magnus carlsen  not to suffer